what's the difference between the
coronavirus family and the
uh the other popular family influenza
virus family
is um
i mean if i were because you mentioned
we should have done a lot more in terms
of vaccine development that kind of
thing for coronaviruses but if i were
back then
from my understanding the thing we
should all be afraid of is influenza
like some
strong variants coming out from that
family that seems like the one that will
destroy human
civilization or uh or hurt us really
badly i don't know if you uh agree with
this sense but maybe
um maybe you can also just clarify what
to use the is the difference between the
families so it's an interesting
difference they both
they both have membranes right
so then they have spike proteins
embedded in them for
and they're different spikes in fact
for influenza there's there are two main
ones they're called the h a and the n a
but what's inside
is rna but it's very different rna
and here we have to explain that so
viruses with rna can have three
different kinds of rna
they can have what we call plus rna
they can have minus
rna or they could have plus minus
actually two strands
hybridized together
the plus rna simply means
that
if you put that plus rna in a cell
you know your cell has ribosomes in it
that make the proteins that you need the
ribosomes will immediately latch on to
the plus rna and begin to make proteins
a minus rna is not the right strand to
make proteins
so it has to be copied first and then
the plus minus is both together so the
sars
coronaviruses all the coronaviruses have
plus rna
so as soon as that rna gets in the cell
boom it starts an infectious cycle same
thing with poliovirus by the way which i
worked on influenza viruses are negative
stranded
so they cannot be translated when they
get in the cell so that that's tough for
the virus because
the cell actually cannot
make plus rna
from minus rna it doesn't have the
enzyme to do it so the virus has to
carry it in
inside the virus particle and then when
the minus rna is in the cell the virus
enzyme makes plus rnas and those get
translated
it's a big difference and then
in the influenza viruses not only is it
minus rna but it's in pieces it's in
eight pieces
we call that segmented whereas the
corona is in one long piece of rna
so what is it is that they're like
floating separately yeah so the genes
are on separate pieces they're all
packaged inside that virus particle of
influenza virus but they're in pieces
and why that's important
is because if two different influenza
viruses
infect the same cell
the pieces as they reproduce can mix and
out can come
a virus with a new assortment of pieces
and that allows influenza virus to
undergo
extremely high frequency evolution
that's why we get pandemics when we have
a new flu pandemics is because somewhere
in some animal
two viruses have reassorted and made a
new virus that we hadn't seen before
so so you're you're you're talking about
kind of
biological characteristics but what am i
incorrect in my intuition that
or from the things i've heard that the
influence of a family of viruses is more
dangerous
like what what makes it more dangerous
to humans
well it depends on the there are many
flavors or vintages of influenza virus
some are dangerous and some are not
right it depends on which one some like
the 1918 apparently was was very lethal
killed a lot of people
but more contemporary viruses we had a
pandemic in 2009
of influenza and that wasn't such a
lethal
virus
we don't know exactly why but it didn't
kill that many people it transmitted
pretty well is that the bird flu one
they're all they're all deriving that
one was called swine influenza swine it
seemed to it
started in a pig but it had bird it had
rnas from bird influenza viruses these
viruses are all reassortance of
different viruses from pigs and birds
and humans
um
but influenza can cause pneumonia and
can kill you as does
soros kobe 2. so it depends on the the
virus so there is another influenza
virus that's currently circulating so
right now we have
the 2009 pandemic virus that's still
around
and then the 1968
pandemic virus which was the one before
2009 that one is still around too and
that's more lethal
and depending on the season some seasons
the 2009 virus predominates some seasons
the 1968 and when the 68 is around you
get more lethality so we're living with
the influenza family we haven't
exterminated them
right we never will never exterminate
them why well because every shore bird
in the world is infected with them you
know gulls and turns and ducks and all
sorts of things but why can't we develop
strong vaccines that defend against oh
we could do that sure
um but that would not eliminate them
from humans even if you had the best
vaccine you would never get rid of it in
people because there would always be
someone who's not vaccinated or in which
the vaccine didn't work you know no but
no vaccine is 100 percent right so
you